[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian
Siebers guten Abend ihnen allen
Demokratien sind verpflichtet Zivilisten
zu schützen das sagt der US
Außenminister Anthony blinken heute er
sagt es bevor er morgen wieder in Israel
erwartet wird und er wird es morgen wohl
wiederholen in Tel Aviv und zwar direkt
gegenüber Ministerpräsident Benjamin
Netanyahu und dessen kriegskabinett die
Amerikaner versuchen ihren israelischen
Verbündeten zu bremsen mit dem Argument
dass es jetzt auf den day after ankomme
den Tag nachdem dieser Krieg vorbei ist
mit dem Argument Israel müsse
langfristiger denken was es jetzt tue
oder eben nicht tue werde direkte
Auswirkungen haben auf seine dauerhafte
Sicherheit Netanyahu dagegen setzt den
Fokus auf die aktuelle Lage seine
Truppen hätten Gaza Stadt erreicht Zitat
Benjamin Netanyahu wir befinden uns auf
dem Höhepunkt der Schlacht aus Tel Aviv
berichtet lck
walport Tag 27 des Kriegs Israels Armee
hat nach eigenen Angaben die Stadt Gaza
umstellt man werde die hamasterroristen
jetzt in direkten kämpfen eliminieren so
ein Armeesprecher international wird der
Ruf nach einer humanitären Feuerpause
lauter morgen wird US Außenminister
blinken darüber mit den israelischen
Partnern beraten Regierungschef netano
zeigt sich bislang kompromisslos er
sendet martialische
Botschaften wir sind auf dem Vormarsch
leider haben wir dabei auch schmerzliche
Verluste aber nichts kann uns
stoppen
was das für die in Gaza verbliebenen
Menschen bedeutet das wurde heute in B
und in magasi südlich der Stadtzentrums
deutlich dieses Haus wurde zerbomt mit
Anwohnern Zivilisten Kindern Eltern und
es gab keine
Warnung auch im flüchtlingsviertel
jabalia gab es wieder Angriffe Helfer
versuchten verzweifelt mit bloßen Händen
Überlebende aus dem Schutt zu bergen
Experten der Vereinten Nationen warnten
heute vor der Gefahr eines Völkermords
die Situation habe einen katastrophalen
Punkt erreicht den Krankenhäusern fehle
vor allem Treibstoff für die
Stromaggregate Israels Armeechef
signalisierte erstmals Bereitschaft das
kriegsembargo zu
lockern Treibstoff kann geliefert werden
unter strenger Aufsicht direkt an die
Krankenhäuser wir werden sicherstellen
dass es nicht von der Hamas genutzt
werden
kann wann das geschieht offen die
Kriegszone verlassen konnten auch heute
wieder mehrere hundert verletzte und
ausländische Bürger die Amerikanerin
Susen psiso schaffte es im fünften
Anlauf ich schwanke zwischen Freude und
Trauer ich weiß nicht ob ich Familie und
Freunde die hier bleiben müssen je
wiedersehen werde die Menschen sterben
hier keiner ist
sicher mehr als 2 Millionen Bewohner des
Gazastreifens haben derzeit keine
Aussicht darauf dem Krieg zu entkommen
auf Hilfe der hamasterroristen können
sie nicht setzen ein hamasprecher sagte
letzte Woche im libanesischen Fernsehen
wörtlich wir sind bereit den Preis zu
zahlen um Israel zu vernichten wir sind
eine Nation von mertyron und stolz
darauf wie sie in Gaza über die
Ansichten ihrer politischen Führung
denken darüber kann man nur
spekulieren spulieren Abed Hassan ist 27
Jahre alt er ist Berliner und zusammen
mit seiner Mutter seit dem 3 Oktober auf
Verwandtenbesuch in Gaza und dann kam
der Krieg Herr Hassan guten
Abend guten Abend jetzt sitzen sie fest
in Gaza ich würde sie gerne zuerst
fragen wie viel Angst haben sie aktuell
also ich bin grundsätzlich eine Person
die immer
versucht Sachen rational zu sehen und
irgendwie irgendwie einfach mit der
Angst quasi so umzugehen aber ich habe
vor allem extrem viel Angst um meine
Verwandten um die Leute die bereits
Familie verloren haben die haben auch
selbst Familie verloren und vor allem um
meine Mutter die es mir ist also das
letzte woran ich denke ist mich selbst
ich denke da am meisten an meine Familie
haben Sie irgendeine Möglichkeit sich da
in Sicherheit zu bringen gibt es sowas
wie ein Keller oder eine Art Bunker oder
irgendetwas was ihn ein bisschen mehr
Sicherheit verschaffen
könnte also das gibt es meiner
Information nach gar nicht in gas
tatsächlich
ähm Bunker gibt es erst recht nicht es
ist auch sehr schwierig überhaupt in
Gasa zu bauen aufgrund der begrenzten
Mittel aufgrund dessen dass immer nur
begrenzte Mittel reinkommen das
sicherste für die Menschen ist
tatsächlich einfach in ihren Häusern zu
bleiben wir versuchen weg von Fenstern
zu bleiben wir bauen die Fenster ab weil
sie weil sie zu gefährlichen also wenn
die Glassplitter auf uns kommen kann das
auch sehr gefährlich werden was manche
Menschen machen wenn Ihre Wohnung
bereits zum Teil zum Teil ist oder
zerbomt ist gehen Sie in die Schulen
oder in
Krankenhäuser sie sind aktuell in Gaza
Stadt jetzt sagt ja Israels Armee immer
wieder alle Menschen sollten in den
Süden des Gazastreifens gehen um dort
sicherer zu sein warum tun sie das nicht
ich tue das nicht
weil viele Leute die in den Süden
gegangen sind auch dort verstorben sind
und der Krieg im ganz Gaza stattfindet
gleichermaßen und bevor ich in einer
Schule lebe oder wo an einem Ort bin der
mir unbekannt ist halte ich mich lieber
bei meiner Familie auf wie hat man sich
denn das das Leben jetzt aktuell in Gaza
vorzustellen gibt es genug zu essen
haben Sie genug zu essen haben Sie genug
zu
trinken ich persönlich bin gerade
erst gerade einmal am Tag aus dem Grund
dass es sehr schwer ist an an Brot
ranzukommen und Brot das
Grundnahrungsmittel hier ist derweiteren
wird mit dem Gas auch irgendwann knapp
und dann kann man auch nicht mehr so
kochen wie vorher wir sind in einer
privilegen Position dass wir finanzielle
Mittel besitzen um uns noch das zu
kaufen was existiert allerdings wird das
was auf dem Markt noch da ist der also
verschwindet langsam also es
verschwinden langsam alle
Grundnahrungsmittel und ich weiß auch
von vielen Haushälten wo die teilweise
auch wirklich gar kein Brot haben
mittlerweile und wir trinken z.B Wasser
ungefiltertes Brunen Wasser weil wir das
Glück haben dass unser Nachbarn brohen
hat aber aber Trinkwasser zu kaufen aus
aus Flaschen z.B ist nahzu unmöglich
haben Sie irgendeine Idee wie lange sie
noch in Gasa festsitzen
werden das kann ich ih nicht sagen Gaza
ist tatsächlich ein Ort der
Überraschungen noch einen Tag vor dem
Krieg saß ich auf den Straßen habe Leute
feiern gesehen lachen gesehen
hochzeitenfernsehen ein Tag später ist
Krieg und ein Tag später ist nur noch
Zerstörung da und genauso ist das mit
den Grenzen die öffnen die schließen die
Lage ändert sich willkürlich also ich
kann nichts abschätzen ich bin schon
auch extrem belastet dadurch dass ich so
lange von meiner Arbeit weg bin
für mich bleibt einfach nur geduldig
sein und Kopf Ruhe bewahren keine
gefährlichen in keine gefährlichen
Situation begeben und ja und einfach
abwarten bis bis Ruhe reinkommt der
Berliner abet Hassan sitzt fest in Gaza
im Krieg Herr Hassan herzlichen Dank für
das Gespräch und alles Gute für sie
vielen Dank ich danke Ihnen für das
Gespräch
das Gespräch haben wir aus
Sicherheitsgründen vor der Sendung
aufgezeichnet wenn ein ausländischer
Politiker wirklichen Einfluss hat auf
das was israels Regierung tut oder nicht
tut dann ist das Joe Biden die USA sind
mit großem Abstand wichtigster
Verbündeter wichtigster Lieferant von
Militärhilfe und wichtigster Geldgeber
damit verschafft man sich Gehör
bemerkenswert wie die US-Regierung
diesen Einfluss nutzt der Außenminister
ich habe ihn vorhin schon zitiert sagt
klar die Zivilbevölkerung in Gaza könne
nichts für die Grausamkeiten der Hamas
sie sei selbst deren Opfer und sein
Präsident hat für eine Pause plädiert im
Krieg auch aus innenpolitischen Gründen
wie Elma tevisson
berichtet eigentlich wollte er Krieg und
Leid für ein paar Stunden hinter sich
lassen auf dem Land in Minnesota werben
für seine Wirtschaftspolitik aber weil
das Thema na Ost die Wähler umtreibt
muss Joe Biden auch hier dazu etwas
sagen wir alle haben die schrecklichen
Bilder aus Gaza gesehen palästinensische
Kinder die nach ihren getöteten Eltern
schreien Trauernde Eltern die die Namen
ihrer Kinder auf deren Hände und Beine
Schreiben zur
Identifizierung der Verlust von
unschuldigen Leben ist eine Tragödie und
wir trauern um diese Toten und auch um
die israelischen Kinder die von den
Hamas Terroristen brutal abgeschlachtet
wurden aber reicht das Mitgefühl für die
Opfer auf beiden Seiten kurz danach bei
einem weiteren Auftritt ruft eine
jüdische Rabbinerin beiden soll einen
Waffenstillstand
fordern burufe beiden antwortet Zitat
wir brauchen eine Pause es sind Worte
die dieser Tage in Washington vor allem
vom linken Flügel der Demokratischen
Partei zu hören
sind muss eine humanitäre Pause her
damit ausreichend Hilfsgüter Nahrung
Wasser Medizin und Treibstoff die
Menschen in Gaza erreichen
können solche Bilder hinterlassen
Wirkung auch bei möglichen Wählern in
den USA vor allem Muslimen die
historisch immer eher demokratisch
wählen Anführer einiger Dutzend
muslimischer Gemeinden starten nun eine
Kampagne l Joe Biden im Stich steht auf
den
Plakaten hier werden bei der Wahl 2024
nicht für Präsident beiden Stimmen das
ist kein leeres Versprechen sondern eine
Garantie Biden und seine Berater wissen
je mehr Kinder sterben desto geringer
die Chance auf einen langfristigen
Frieden in der Region gleichzeitig
wollen sie kein Jota Abweichen von
Israels Recht sich zu verteidigen auch
die Hamas zu vernichten ein unmöglicher
Spagat für die
US-Politik gibt es eine Grenze für für
das was Israel denen antut die Juden
abschlachten nein keine Grenze aber wir
sollten klug handeln zivile Opfer so gut
es geht
begrenzen wir sollten wenigstens aktiv
versuchen das Töten von Kindern Frauen
unschuldigen Zivilisten zu stoppen das
entspräche den Werten der Vereinigten
Staaten genau deshalb reist Anthony
blinken jetzt mit einem Auftrag nach
Israel wir werden über konkrete Schritte
reden die manreen könnte und sollte um
das Leiden der Männer Frauen und Kinder
in Gaza zu
minimieren wie das gehen soll ließ er
offen aber die Botschaft an Israel ist
klar und in Deutschland ein knapp Z
minütiges Video das der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister aufgenommen
hat einige Gedanken wie er es selbst
nennt zur Solidarität mit Israel und
gegen Antisemitismus Robert habbeck wird
wissen dass er damit ziemlich tief St
App seine Gedanken gerieten zu einer
Rede zur Lage der Nation zu einem Appell
der auch von einem kommen könnte manche
sagen kommen müsste der nicht nur
Vizekanzler ist sondern Regierungschef
auf jeden Fall ist das heute redethema
in diesem Land Karl Hinterleitner der
Satz Israels Sicherheit ist deutsche
staatsresant war nie eine lehrformel und
er darf auch keine werden er sagt dass
die Sicherheit Israels für uns als Staat
notwendig ist wir haben sicherlich oft
zu viel Empörung in unserer
Debattenkultur aber hier können wir gar
nicht empört genug sein es braucht jetzt
Klarheit und kein verwischen die
deutsche Diplomatie aber scheint
manchmal eher unklar bei der
UN-Resolution vergangene Woche die den
Terror der Hammers nicht klar beim Namen
nannte stimmte Deutschland nicht etwa
dagegen sondern enthielt sich die
Außenministerin gestern im ZF bei was
nun mit
Begründungen es gibt nicht die eine
Sichtweise in dieser furchtbaren
Situation das habe ich ja auch vor den
Vereinten Nationen deutlich gemacht wenn
wir dafür sorgen wollen dass Israel
endlich in Frieden und Sicherheit leben
kann dann müssen wir bereit sein uns
immer wieder in die Schuhe des anderen
aufzustellen das klingt nicht wirklich
eindeutig aber es sei aus ihrem Amt
heraus erklärbar meinen politische
Beobachter die Rede von Robert habbeck
ist völlig anders intoniert als die
Reden von Annalena berborg das hat einen
entscheidenden Grund berborg begreift
sich auch als Mittlerin zwischen der
Welt auch wenn sie immer Israel vor
allem Interesse Israels im Schilde führt
Robert hab hat zuallererst eine
innenpolitisch grundierte Rede gehalten
diese Rede ist an Deutschland gerichtet
denn in Deutschland wird das Versprechen
der staatsresort gerade auf die Probe
gestellt Proteste auf den Straßen gegen
Israel Jubel und Zustimmung für die
Hamas auch dazu ein deutliches
Bekenntnis von habek für religiöse
Intoleranz ist in Deutschland kein Platz
wer hier lebt lebt nach den Regeln
dieses Landes und wer hierherkmt muss
wissen dass das so ist und so auch
durchgesetzt werden
wird klare Worte die auch bei der
Opposition Anerkennung finden robert
habck hat als erstes Mitglied dieser
Bundesregierung aus meiner Sicht den
richtigen Ton getroffen es war eine
empathische Rede aber es war eben auch
eine erklärende Rede die deutlich
gemacht hat welche zesur der 7 Oktober
sowohl für die Menschen in Israel als
auch für jüdische Menschen in
Deutschland
bedeutet und auch im politischen Berlin
sieht man in habcks Rede eine neue
Qualität den Begriff der staatsreson wie
eine Monstranz vor sich herzutragen ist
das eine das ist in den Reden von Olaf
Scholz aber auch von Annalena berburg
immer wieder vorgekommen das aber was
erforderlich ist und genau das leistet
die Rede von Robert habck ist es diese
staatsrison herunterzubrechen auf die
Notwendigkeit jüdisches Leben in
Deutschland zu schützen es zu
verteidigen und zu verhindern dass in
diesem Land noch einmal Juden und Jüden
nicht sicher sind das hat hab geleistet
und damit verleiht er den Begriff der
statsrison ein Leben wie es die anderen
bisher nicht geleistet haben die
Sicherheit Israels als staatsrison
jahrelang ein Hees Prinzip das sich aber
kaum konkret beweisen musste diese
Zeiten sind vorbei und wir bleiben noch
beim Thema nostkonflikt und den Folgen
für Deutschland jetzt mit dir Hanna ja
denn hierzulande gilt seit heute für die
Terrororganisation Hamas und das
proalästinensische Netzwerk samidun ein
Betätigungsverbot das gab in Ministerin
fäer am Morgen bekannt der deutsche
Ableger des Vereins samidun wird zuudem
aufgelöst fäer erklärte zur Begründung
dass Antisemitismus in Deutschland
keinen Platz habe und mit Härte bekämpft
werde die Anordnung erleichtert es nun
den Behörden bei Versammlungen
einzuschreiten in Deutschland ist die
Bedrohung durch Cyberkriminelle deutlich
gestiegen das zeigt der neue Lagebericht
des Bundesamts für Sicherheit in der
Informationstechnik dabei geht es etwa
um Erpressung Datendiebstahl und
Spionage die Anzahl der täglich
festgestellten Schwachstellen in
Softwareprodukten sei im Vergleich zum
Vorjahr fast um ein Viertel gestiegen
bevorgzugt würden kleinere und mittlere
Unternehmen sowie kommunale Verwaltungen
angegriffen durch den Missbrauch von
künstlicher Intelligenz könnte die
Bedrohung laut BSI noch weiter
wachsen Außenministerin bbock hat
tiefgreifende Reformen in der EU
gefordert und Vorschläge dazu
unterbreitet gerade mit Blick auf den
möglichen Beitritt weiterer Länder seien
diese nötig um handlungsfähig zu bleiben
sagte berborg auf einer Konferenz mit
europäischen außenministerinnen und
Ministern in Berlin berbock sprach sich
unter anderem dafür aus mehr
Entscheidungen nach dem Mehrheitsprinzip
zu fällen zudem dürften EU-Kommission
und Parlament auch bei einer Erweiterung
nicht noch größer werden ein schweres
Orkantief mit Windgeschwindigkeiten von
bis zu 200 km pro Stunde ist über den
Nordwesten Europas hinweggefegt
mindestens sieben Menschen kamen ums
Leben in Frankreich waren etwa 1,2
Millionen Haushalte zeitweise ohne Strom
umgestürzte Bäume blockierten Straßen
auch der Zugverkehr viel vielerorts aus
an den Küsten gab es Meter hohe
Sturmwellen in Deutschland kam es vor
allem in Nordrhein-Westfalen zu Schäden
im Harz stabb eine Frau durch einen
umgestürzten
Baum im Schatten des narostkrieges auf
den wir hier ja intensiv schauen spielt
sich weiter östlich an der Grenze von
Pakistan zu Afghanistan ein Drama ab
pakistan hat damit begonnen
Schutzsuchende im Land ohne
Aufenthaltsgenehmigung festzunehmen und
plant
Massenabschiebungen das betrifft vor
allem Menschen aus Afghanistan von denen
Millionen ins Nachbarland geflohen sind
manche von ihnen gerade erst vor der
Herrschaft der Taliban und sich jetzt
auf die lange beschwerliche Reise
zurückmachen in eine mehr als ungewisse
Zukunft Johannes
hanno mit allem was sie auf die Schnelle
noch mitnehmen konnten machen sie sich
auf Richtung Afghanistan R 200.000
Afghanen haben Pakistan bislang
freiwillig verlassen und doch gegen
ihren
Willen wir haben fast 40 Jahre in
Pakistan gelebt aber sie haben uns nie
anerkannt uns nie irgendwelche Dokumente
ausgestellt damit wir bleiben können sie
hätten uns wenigstens ein Jahr Zeit
geben sollen aber so kurzfristig nur ein
Monat wir mussten alles billig verkaufen
jetzt sind wir auf dem Weg nach
Afghanistan der Winter kommt und es wird
keine Arbeit für uns geben Anfang
Oktober hatte die pakistanische
Regierung angekündigt ab November mehr
als 2 Millionen sogenannte illegale
Flüchtlinge abzuschieben der offizielle
Grund warum die Regierung plötzlich so
unbarmherzig gegen die Flüchtlinge
vorgeht Polizei und Geheimdienst machen
sie für Selbstmordattentate und
Anschläge im Land verantwortlich der
Innenminister mach in eine vergangeneen
Woche noch einmal klar Kompromisse wird
es bei der Abschiebung keine
geben
ich warne alle die hier illegal leben
sie sollten besser freiwillig gehen
bevor wir sie
zwangsdeortieren wir haben unsere
Hausaufgaben gemacht wir wissen wo sich
alle
aufhalten wie kompromisslos die
pakistanische Regierung vorgeht wurde
gestern Nachmittag in Islamabad klar in
den Trümmern ihrer einfachen lebenhäuser
suchen afghanische Flüchtlinge nach den
Resten ihrer Existenz nach Ablauf des
Ultimatums waren die bulldoer gekommen
haben die Flüchtlingssiedlung
niedergewalzt ich habe noch nie in
Afghanistan gelebt ich kam als Säugling
und so behandelt uns die pakistanische
Regierung jetzt schau das waren unsere
Häuser das ist unsere Situation jetzt
wer keine gültigen papi hat und
freiwillig nicht geht wird festgenommen
und
zwangsdeportiert darunter auch viele
Menschen die von den Taliban nach deren
Macht Übernahme 2021 geflohen waren das
flüchtlingskommissariat der Vereinten
Nationen alarmier
Afghanistan steht vor großen humanitären
Herausforderungen auch für die
Menschenrechte von Mädchen und Frauen
und wir glauben dass das Vorgehen der
pakistanischen Regierung schwerwiegende
Folgen für alle Vertriebenen hat die be
Rückkehr um ihre Sicherheit fürchten
müssen allein am völlig überlasteten
Grenzübergang torkam kommen täglich um
die 1000 zwangsheimkehrer an auf
afghanischer Seite dann werden sie mit
blumenrenzen und schnellfollgewehren
begrüßt die Taliban lassen keinen
Zweifel aufkommen wer ab jetzt über ihr
Leben
entscheidet und jetzt zurück nach
Deutschland bzw genauer zu einem
Unternehmen das weltumspannend Geld
verdient und zwar viel Geld Hanna ja
trotz Krisenstimmung in weiten Teilen
der deutschen Wirtschaft die lufthanser
konnte heute einen Rekordgewinn
verkünden der vergangene Sommer war der
profitabelste in der der
Unternehmensgeschichte Stephanie Barrett
so ein Höhenflug wie ist der zu erklären
also die luftthanse hat natürlich enorm
von der Reiselust der Menschen nach der
Pandemie profitiert dank der Milliarden
Staatshilfen konnte sie die desaströse
Krise überhaupt nur überstehen die
Staatsgelder sind im übrigen seit Ende
letzten Jahres auf Heller und Cent
zurückgezahlt in diesem Fall hat sich
der Einstieg des Bundes also durchaus
gelohnt die Kundschaft ist zurück und
dank hoher Nachfrage konnte die
lufthanse auch deutlich höhere
Ticketpreise durchsetzen im Schnitt
liegen sie etwa 25% über dem vorcoron
Niveau und haben das glänzende Ergebnis
ermöglicht für Aktionäre dagegen war die
lufthanser in der Vergangenheit ein
Verlustgeschäft muss man sagen gegenüber
2019 hat sich ihr Wert mal eben halbiert
Geduld und ein langer Atem sind dann
noch nötig auch wenn die Aktie heute
wieder gefragter war ja und es gibt auch
Herausforderungen für den Konzern welche
sind das ja ganz aktuell ist natürlich
ist sie wie alle anderen Airlines mit
den geopolitischen Unsicherheiten
konfrontiert wobei interessanterweise
die Buchungen in der gesamten
naostregion nach dem Terroranschlag nur
vorübergehend gesunken sind es wächst
aber die Nervosität an den Ölmärkten
schon in diesem Jahr fällt die
treibstoffrechnung schätzungsweise eine
halbe Milliarde Euro höher aus als noch
im letzten Jahr und nicht zuletzt steht
die Frage im Raum ob die Reisebudgets
der Verbraucher auch im kommenden Jahr
noch so prall gefüllt sein werden und ob
sie sich so teure Urlaubsreisen noch
leisten können vielen Dank Stefanie für
diese Einordnung
die übliche Herbstbelebung am
Arbeitsmarkt ist im Oktober nur gering
ausgefallen grund sei die
wirtschaftliche Schwäche erklärte die
Chefin der Bundesagentur für Arbeit
nales im Oktober waren laut ihrer
Behörde rund 2,6 Millionen Menschen
arbeitslos das sind 20.000 weniger als
im Vormonat aber
165 000 mehr als im vergangenen Jahr zu
dieser Zeit die Arbeitslosenquote liegt
wie im September bei 5,7%
der Trainer von Bundesliga Schlusslicht
Mainz 05 B senson ist zurückgetreten der
44-Jährige zieht damit die Konsequenzen
aus dem schlechtesten Saisonstart der
Clubgeschichte nach neuen Spieltagen ist
Mainz noch immer ohne Sieg gestern volle
die Mannschaft in der zweiten Runde des
DFB Pokals gegen zweitliges Herter BSC
übergangsweise übernimmt nun der
bisherige U23 Coach Jan sieer
Tennisprofi Alexander SEV ist beim ATP
Masters Turnier in Paris bers im
Achtelfinale ausgeschieden der
Weltranglisten neun verlor gegen den
Griechen Stefano zizipas in zwei Sätzen
ZF muss nun um die Qualifikation für die
ATP Finals Mitte November in Turin
bangen sie war die erfolgreichste
eiskunstlauftrainerin der Welt und
formte Katharina wi zum Superstar da nun
ist juta Müller mit 94 Jahren gestorben
die gebürtige kemnitzerin war zunächst
selbst ddrmeisterin im Paarlauf bevor
sie Trainerin wurde der große Erfolg kam
mit Tochter Gabi Seifer die Sie zu
mehreren EM und WM tieln führte Müller
galt als streng und passioniert sie
trainierte weitere große Namen wie Jan
Hoffmann Annette pöch und eben Katharina
Witt insgesamt 57 Medaillen bei
Olympischen Spielen Welt und
Europameisterschaften so die Bilanz
Müllers als
Trainerin man kann von künstlicher
Intelligenz halten was man will aber die
Beatles sind wieder da 53 Jahre nach
ihrer Trennung haben sie einen neuen
Song ja sie haben mit John Lennon mit
George Harrison und den anderen
sowieso das sind sie hier beim letzten
Live Konzert 19 69 es ist also ziemlich
emotional now and then jetzt und damals
heißt der Song und da verschwimmt beides
so ein bisschen now and then der
künstlichen Intelligenz sei Dank Claudio
Armbruster so oder so ähnlich mag es
sich wohl zugetragen haben irgendwann
Ende der 70er John Lennon spielt Klavier
zu Hause neue Lieder und nimmt sie auf
mit seinem gassettenrekord
[Musik]
und heute so viele Jahre später
erscheint also ein neuer Beatles
Song doch langsam der Reihe nach 1994
gibt jokoono den drei noch lebenden
Beatles die Kassette darauf drei Lieder
von
John und Paul George und Ringo machen
sich ans Werk kurz darauf erscheinen
zwei neue Beatles Songs free as a bird
und Real Love doch am dritten now and
then scheitern die drei Johns Stimme zu
weit weg das Klavier zu trüb also gaben
sie auf und now and then blieb liegen
bis vor einem Jahr der Filmregisseur
Peter Jackson Paul McCartney und Ringo
Star eine von ihm entwickelte
Technologie zeigte die einzelne Stimmen
und Instrumente sauber voneinander
trennen kann auf Basis maschinellen
Lernens KI lässt grüßen Problem gelöst
also namahmen sie auf Paul am Bass Ringo
am Schlagzeug und von George hatten sie
noch ein Gitarrensolo in der Schublade
und fertig war er der neue und wohl auch
der letzte Beatles
[Musik]
Song
ja natürlich sind das nicht die Beatles
natürlich ist dieser Song vor allem auch
ein gutes Geschäft für die Macher und
das Label aber nun das Lied ist halt
auch einfach
schön das reicht uns in diesen Tagen
danke dass heute mit uns dabei waren
beim Blick auf diese Welt die Kollegin
malbrit ner begrüßt gleich unter anderem
den Außenminister der Ukraine und fragt
Ukraine und Israel zwei gefährliche
Kriege für die
Welt ja und unser heute journal Update
gibt's dann gegen 0:30 Uhr mit nasan
gckdem mir vom gesamten Team hier auch
den Kolleginnen und Kollegen hinter den
Kameras an sie einen angenehmen Abend
tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend das hier ist die
Windsituation heute Nacht da sehen sie
noch das orkanef Kiron hier über der
Nordsee und weitere Tiefs eins über ober
Italien eins vor Frankreich und über dem
Atlantik braut sich schon der nächste
Sturm fürs Wochenende zusammen wir
schauen uns jetzt aber diese Tiefs mal
etwas genauer an dieses Tief über ober
Italien bringt viel en und in den Alpen
erhalb von 1000 m auch Schnee und es
bringt auch Orkanböhen mit
Windgeschwindigkeiten von mehr als 150
km pro Stunde über dem apenin und dann
gibt's da ja noch ein weiteres Tief und
das schauen wir uns jetzt genauer an
hier über Frankreich denn das bringt
Orkanböhen an die Atlantikküste hier in
Westfrankreich vielleicht kommen diese
Orkanböhen mit 150 km pro Stunde auch in
Bordeaux an deutlich ruhiger ist es bei
uns stürmische Böhen werden sich in
dieser Nacht auf die nordseküste
beschränken im im Osten fät Regen und an
den Alpen oberhalb von 1000 m auch
Schnee im Westen ist es zum Teil nur
locker bewölkt dann bildet sich Nebel
die Temperaturen sinken auf 10 bis 2°
und morgen bleibt es kühler als heute
mit Höchstwerten zwischen 6 und 12°. der
Regen zieht morgen ostwärts ab
vielleicht gehbt's am Alpenrand noch
nasse Schneeflocken dann wird's ganz
freundlich am Nachmittag entwickeln sich
besonders im Nordwesten einige
Regenschauer und einzelne stürmische
böhnen an der Nordsee sind nicht völlig
ausgeschlossen am Samstag wird's dann
stürmisch im Westen am Sonntag im
Südwesten insgesamt ist es im Osten
trockener und sonniger als im Westen
guten
Abend